all right something that we didn't get
to today because there really wasn't
enough time to delve into it not that
we're going to take 20 minutes to talk
about it but
yeah i was encouraged last week chris
regarding the idea that for the replay
review of pass interference in order to
activate automatic review which happens
final two minutes of either half over
time on a touchdown player on a turnover
that the nfl had changed the standard
making it harder to activate an
automatic review there was talk would
this be a coach's challenge no it's
still going to be automatic review but
in order to initiate the automatic
review the standards been flipped for
automatic reviews for every other play
that is subject to replay review the
standard is this there will only be an
automatic review if there isn't clear
and obvious evidence that the ruling on
the field was correct meaning you need
to have a high bar clear and obvious
that it's correct anything short of that
we have a replay review to see if
there's clear and obvious evidence that
the ruling was incorrect well for most
rulings there isn't a very big band
between clear and obviously correct
versus clear and obviously wrong for
pass interference there's a huge gulf of
potential pushing and shoving and maybe
it was and maybe it wasn't so the nfl
has decided
in order to even activate automatic
review there has to be clear and obvious
evidence the ruling on the field was
wrong the same standard that gets
applied during the actual replay review
well okay that's fine when we're talking
about nikhil roby-coleman and tommy lee
lewis in the nfc championship game when
everyone says it was clearly and
obviously an error right nikhil royal we
call and got there early the problem is
and and this is concerning me now
because al riverand showed a group from
nfl media a play from week 15 chris
chargers chiefs it was a call of
interference on kendall fuller the
chief's defensive back defensive pass
interference riveron told this group
that that would have been reviewed and
it would have become offsetting fouls
because mike williams pushed off you see
the arm push of kendall fuller it would
have been offsetting fouls the chargers
wouldn't have the ball at the one they
would have the ball back at the 10 again
there would have been eight seconds left
and they would have had to try to score
a touchdown maybe they would have maybe
they wouldn't have right but the bottom
line is this
how do we get past that high bar to even
have an automatic review on a play where
it's a little more gray right it's not
quite what we saw a ram saints game yes
that's my concern there's a line there
somewhere
how do you keep 17 replay officials on
the right side of that line i i don't
know mike and that's why i've been
scared of you know some of this uh you
know
review challenge past interference
conversation all together because yes
still at the end of the day we're going
to have a guy in a booth who you know
hey yeah the guy in kansas city might go
no that's clear and obvious we're going
to review it but you know there could be
a guy in another state you know back in
new york
the same exact play happens and he goes
that's not clear and obvious we're not
going to review that i mean there was no
problem there so again we're getting
into human judgment there to what they
seem uh or deem as clear and obvious and
for me and the other thing too is man i
mean you're gonna have a very very
trained eye right we're not gonna watch
these replays in slow motion it's either
see it real time or see a real-time
replay right and that you're gonna have
to be ver a very trained eyed to really
find kind of see everything right in
that way and there's certainly gonna be
some things that i would think with that
with that set of uh how it's set up
where i would go no they're gonna miss
some too then if they're gonna watch it
that way too and yeah i just don't know
how this is gonna play out but yes it
scares me from missing calls still or or
a play should have been reviewed and it
wasn't or we end up getting too many
reviews down the stretch all of those
things are what concern me
and and again
the replay official is now the
gatekeeper for automatic review and the
replay official has to see clear and
obvious evidence of an error on a pass
interference call or an on-call
offensive or defensive with real-time
view or full-speed replay before it ever
gets to al river on and that's the thing
that was glossed over by this idea that
riveron is showing them the chiefs
chargers play and saying hey this would
have been offsetting fouls how does it
get to al river on this tells me this
play is clearly and obviously wrong
enough that the replay official should
say oh oh okay
activate the automatic replay review
that's where i'm concerned because it's
not nearly as clear as ram's saints so
here's where the nfl needs to get on the
same page all the teams all the teams
all the the people in the front office
all the officials they need to
understand
when
that button that proverbial button will
be pressed when in doubt what do you do
well you know what when in doubt you
don't press the button because it's not
clear and obvious if there's any doubt
and i think with that mike williams play
there's enough there that it doesn't
jump off the page i just think it needs
to be something just wow they clearly
missed that right anything other than
that you don't slow down the game with
replay review of a pass interference
call otherwise they're gonna have five
of them every game in the fourth quarter
no i know and that's where i think
you're going to get into some arguments
because there's going to be some replay
review officials that their eyes not as
trained as bill belichick and bill
belichick is going to be on the sideline
going that was clear and obvious past
interference they're going to review
that right and you know whoever the
replay view uh official is up in the
booth his eye is not as strange as bill
belichick he might not see it or if he
does see it he might not think it's
egregious and oh it didn't really affect
that guy that much it's not clear and
obvious i'm not gonna review it and
that's where i think they're gonna
you're gonna go down a wormhole of
discrepancies there and where you might
see uh some some dysfunctional things
with this conversation going forward and
how the coaches see it and how the
replay and how
ever riveron and his staff see it so uh
i'm i'm truly interested to see how this
plays out and how it all gets executed
i'm just hoping that you can pull the
game down like you said
let me add one thing and i'm gonna be as
diplomatic as i can be there is a sense
in league circles that al river on is
going to struggle with this assignment
and a certain element of this replay
official having the high standard before
you say boom let's have the automatic
review of past interference calls and
non-calls one of the reasons for the
high standard they're concerned that al
is going to take that he's going to
overanalyze it and and it's going to be
it's going to take too long and there's
going to be too many of these that that
that get overturned or partially
returned i mean think about it well two
years ago there was a lot of clear and
obvious the plays that weren't clear and
obvious that he overturned and that was
reception right with ketchup exactly
right and with pass interference there's
so much there that you can see i mean i
when i watched that that replay of the
call on kendall fuller
i could do a replay review of that and
because here's the thing it's all you
know for a lot of these did you get two
feet down yes or no right are you
inbounds are you out of bounds did the
ball touch the ground whatever for this
it's not just
was there past interference committed by
the defense was there past interference
committed by the offense what was you
know the ruling on the field well the
ruling was it was pass interference on
the defense and necessarily no pass
interference on the offense so what are
we really looking at here i guess we're
looking at all of it
yes and remember i've said chris that
this idea that offsetting fouls let's
have a do-over that that's going to be
something we're going to see
a lot of as a matter of replay review i
never i don't recall ever hearing uh ad
hocule
turn on his microphone and say we have
offsetting fouls on the play pass
interference offense past interference
defense it's one of the other it's never
both on replay review i have a feeling
it's going to be both a lot they're just
going to do the play over yeah i i i
hear you i think that is going to be one
of the things like you know well we go
into like i thought of too like the
replay or the play from two years ago
maybe it's three years ago now remember
the famous julio jones richard sherman
passing interference right i mean that
was clear and obvious should have been
perseverance right right but at the line
of scrimmage exactly julio jones whacked
sherman in the head to get separation
right so yeah i mean i'm with you mike i
think we're gonna see a lot of that go
on and then they're gonna replay the
down and we're gonna go wow we wasted
three minutes of time just to replay the
down that's great and i think that's
gonna annoy some people
well but you know is it technically
getting it right i don't i don't know i
mean there's a balance between getting
it right
and not bogging the game down you know
it's gonna be like basketball where the
last two minutes of the game take a half
hour because every pass play is going to
be subject to that hey is there enough
there for us to take a look at it
upstairs and they better be sure that
the replay officials know what the hell
they're doing and they better be sure al
riveron knows what the hell he's doing
or this is going to be a mess and this
is not the thing that they want marring
season 100 season 100 is a big deal and
it's going to be less of a big deal if
the past interference replay review rule
screws everything
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports